oh look it's my cousin fal cousin fal
what can i do for you hey sam what's up
oh well not much i'm just sitting here
uh thinking about uh what video i i
should do next well then maybe you can
help me i'm starting a shape collection
okay so so how do you need help well
look at these shapes over here i have no
way to classify them
okay well um
there's a bunch of ways that you could
classify them the first way you could
you could think about how many sides
each of these shapes have so that's one
way to think about it how many sides
they have
how did i figure that out okay well um
let's let's look at each of these and
and think about how many sides they have
so
this first shape right over here this is
one side
we see this kind of straight right over
here it's it's the it's the straight
line between these two corners so that's
one side
two sides
three sides and four sides so this shape
right over here is four sides okay i
think i get it what about this shape
right over here okay um well let's see
uh this one well same idea this one also
looks like it has one
two
three
and four
four sides
what about this one okay uh well this
one actually this is interesting this
one actually has no corners and it has
no sides there's no there's no straight
edges over here this thing is all curved
so since it has no corners it also has
no size or at least the way that i'm
thinking about it so i would say that
this one over here has zero sides
zero zero let me write that a little bit
neater for you okay yeah i like to write
things really neat okay zero sides and
it has zero corners actually let me
write them for all of them this one has
four sides
and we can also count the corners we
have one that's where the two sides meet
one two
three four corners
four
corners
this shape over here it also has
four sides we already counted that it
has one
two three
four corners so four sides and four
corners actually describes both of these
shapes this one has zero sides and zero
corners what about the green one okay
well let's see one side two sides
three sides and four sides and it also
has one two three
four corners so this is also four sides
and four corners is also true of that
one there do all shapes have four sides
and four corners no no no not at all i
mean well you know this one right over
here zero sides and zero corners and
actually this this last shape right over
here doesn't seem to have four sides or
four corners if we count them we have
one
side
two sides
and three sides so this one has three
sides
and if we count the corners we have one
corner two corners
and three
corners oh thanks a bunch of cousins al
but but one i always get confused
whether you're my cousin or my my my
uncle but when i'll call you cousins out
but but what i read in a shape magazine
that there's other ways that i can
classify i can classify it based on
whether the sides have the same size so
which of these have all the sides are
the same size
okay well calm down
let's let's look at this so if you look
at this one it has four sides but we see
that this side right over here this
green side is clearly shorter than this
purple side so all the four sides here
are not the same length but if we look
at this shape right over here this side
at least looks like the same length as
this side and that looks like the same
length as this side and that looks like
the same length as that side so it looks
over here like all four sides are the
same length and that's also true for
this shape this side looks the same
length as that side looks the same
length as that side and it's also true
for this three-sided shape
this side looks the same length as that
side it's the same length as that one oh
thank you so much cousins al i'm ready
to go classify my shape collection this
is awesome oh i'm i'm glad that i could
i could help